i want to formally congratulate you
thank you you are bad girl yes
how did you find out that you got this
incredible role and how did you react
yeah ah man it was a crazy shock i mean
obviously i had been auditioning um it
was a whole process you know but it was
just like mind-bending it's still
mind-bending to like think about it and
we're about to just embark on this
insane journey but i found out
via zoom the directors in the studio
were were on and they kind of like made
try to make it a surprise they tried to
make it like i was doing a final test
and then they sent me an email saying
i'm batgirl and had me read it and i was
just like i'm not reading that i don't
know what's happening right now
you didn't know you had it you thought
that you were auditioning again yeah i
thought that i was doing it i was doing
a follow-up test and then they just had
me had me read that we have good news
for you yeah it was insane it was
beautiful and it's just it's a blessing
i'm so excited about the character i'm
excited to nerd out with all of the
comics
um i've already been doing so much
research on it and so i'm just i'm
excited to learn how to kick some butt
too because your girl she's gonna she's
gonna have to get rough and tough to be
miss barbara gordon so correct i cannot
wait in that case
let's see what batgirl can do
what are you most excited to surprise
fans with with your take on batgirl you
put a little bit of yourself into each
each character and just in the bit of
research that i've been doing leading
into pre-production i've learned a lot
of things about barbara that are very in
line with with me and so i'm excited
she's someone who's been you know
underestimated by her own even her own
dad and like just you know being a the
youngest kid sometimes you're insulated
from all of the like tough stuff of life
and she's so eager to just prove to
herself and to everybody else that she
there's some things that she can handle
um and so this journey is definitely
going to show me a lot of that that i
feel like i'm on an endless journey of
like proving to myself what i what
barriers i can break what limits i can i
can break for myself and i'm excited to
put a little bit of that eagerness and
just drive and like
almost a bit of stubbornness into into
barbara's character barbara badass
leslie badass yeah let's go have you
seen the costume have you tried on a
costume oh i'm dying they haven't told
me anything i honestly cannot leak
anything even if i knew but i have no
idea and i think probably until i head
off
um i won't i won't know much but i'm
dying to know what that what that uh
what that outfit looks like i know that
i'm gonna be fitting like
like 35 different fittings for this
it's a big deal yeah it's a big deal so
we want to get it right so i'm excited
to see what that process is going to be
like too i think you saw the clip when
et told margot robbie that you had
landed the role of batgirl have you seen
that in the heights is leslie grace is
going to be a batgirl and do you feel
like you two could see that yes she's
gonna be cool
that's wicked she's amazing i was
freaking out i was like i'm such a fan
i'm like
i can't even i mean she's one of the
biggest badasses in the superhero world
have you had a chance to connect i
haven't haven't had a chance to meet her
but it it would be awesome miss margo
hi i just want to say i'm a huge fan and
you know if if if it's a good idea if
you think it's a good idea for harley
quinn to stop by you know i mean we're
welcoming all of the help batman's out
he's doing a whole bunch of stuff so i'm
gonna need some of my ladies to help me
out on on on this next run you know what
i'm saying we love you
what does the name jk simmons mean to
you oh my gosh
what
i am freaking out about that i think
that's one of like top things on my
brain like oh my gosh
how many of you are there
not enough
if you were to play your dad how would
you feel about that
but hypothetically here i'm ready to
learn a lot a lot from from from jk
simmons jk simmons if you're listening
huge respect and please play my dad i
hope you're my dad
i love it i'll talk to him tonight
you're in this incredible season of life
what are you most excited about this new
era of leslie grace i'm just excited
like i said about barbara you know um
prove some new things to myself just try
new things and
shatter
any any limitations that i might have in
my own brain and for everyone else as
well i feel just so blessed to to be
able to do the things that i do every
day that are really
my passion and to share it with the
people that have been supporting me
along the way i mean my fans are
incredible they they have grown with me
and shout out grace nation yes shout out
grace nation great solution
uh that's what that's what we're on so i
can't wait to just continue this journey
along with everybody that's a part of
the family
batgirl and three adjectives determined
capable and
purpose driven
[Music]